how is this part of you working your way
back into hollywood and and
you know i've never thought of myself as
working my way well no no no but let's
say as you reintroduce yourself to the
public okay how is this um it's
wonderful you know this has always been
the plan to to expand my uh my empire so
to speak
um to expand the the level of what i
want to do and and also to you know i
got i got the opportunity to direct
multiple episodes of the show and as
well as my music videos that directed
all them but to be able to usher in just
a new generation of artists of actors of
of just these amazing this amazing
talent that's out there that has so much
to tell that's what is feeding me what
do you say to all those people who stood
by you throughout all this oh my
goodness they i i tell them you know
just with all my heart just just thank
you they never wavered they never
straddled the fence and and for that i'm
forever grateful i don't take that
lightly i don't take it lightly for a
moment and um uh my family my friends
the the true ones supporters is just
it's you know if i never get to hug you
in person just know that like there's a
hug in my heart that i genuinely
genuinely mean more music absolutely
when uh very soon what kind of music uh
uh very good music
[Music]